[Musique]
i want
j'aime beaucoup la biologie savoir
comment les corps fonctionne c'est
comment on est fait
coralie nicoué à 19 ans elle est une
attikamek de la communauté de manawan
coralie étudie en sciences au cégep de
lanaudière à joliette
elle devrait entrer en médecine en
septembre son intérêt pour la médecine
vient aussi d'expérience très
personnelle vécue dans une communauté
éloignée qui manque de soins monsieur
quand j'étais jeune acer faisait ce
qu'on dit comme des attaques et on était
obligé ma mère je la voyais parti en
ambulance d'urgence pour la joliette ça
m'a marqué en tant qu'enfant
il est 5 heures du matin une trentaine
d'étudiants de l'université de montréal
en médecine se dirige vers manawan
presque cinq heures de route pour
plusieurs il s'agit d'une première
visite dans une communauté autochtone
ces étudiants viennent à la rencontre
d'élèves du secondaire
il leur propose une introduction aux
sciences de la santé à travers des
activités où l'idée est d'abord de
s'amuser et sait-on jamais suscité aussi
des vocations médical bonne occasion
pour que les chantiers bas qu'ils
veulent avec yvette dans la médecine et
c'est l'art c'est aujourd'hui qu'ils
peuvent savoir plus en plus les
autochtones on tenait pourtant retard à
combler sur le plan de l'éducation
supérieure 9% des autochtones possède un
diplôme universitaire c'est presque
trois fois moins que la population non
autochtone et plus rares encore sont les
diplômés en sciences de la santé
dans ce contexte garder les jeunes
autochtones aux études constitue le défi
on encourage beaucoup nos jeunes à se
doter d'un rêve qui vont faire en sorte
d'année motivés qui les intéressent
sagaie ottawa le directeur de l'école au
tapis à lui-même complété des études
universitaires
il sait ce que veut dire sortir de sa
communauté
être confronté à d'autres habitudes à
une autre culture dans une langue qui
n'est pas la vôtre
on a des gens qui ont quand lucie malgré
tout les embauches à la discrimination
le docteur eric drouhin responsable des
caravanes de futurs professionnels de la
santé au début en 2011 on souhaitait
favoriser la persévérance scolaire chez
les jeunes autochtones uc depuis dear
effet l'objectif d'être serré plus de
professionnels de la santé chez les
autochtones
étudiants sont jamais ans j'ai eu très
peu de contacts à montréal dans les
grandes villes avec les communautés
toute la communication avec un patient
d'automne est différente
quelque sorte de passionnés un dock
tonnes sur le non verbal entre autres
soient détendus silence qui a pendant
l'entrevue sur les regards qui est
différent donc on essaie de pratiquer sa
aussi pendant à l'intérieur de la
faculté des sons de drogue
n'importe quoi hubert et william sont
deux étudiants de première année en
médecine la pratique en milieu
autochtone les intéresse ils tentent ici
d'échanger avec les élèves sur la
toxicomanie
je pense que c'est une communauté qui
parfois délaissés par les gens qui
pratiquent la santé je trouve que ce
soit ce qui est dommage parce que c'est
quand même une population qui vit
beaucoup de problématiques de santé il
ya beaucoup de maladies chroniques parce
qu'on se rend compte en venant ici c'est
que les gens n'ont exactement le même
potentiel que n'importe où au québec
c'est évident on est des conversations
avec eux et c'est évident par contre si
on veut je m'en contrer le décrochage
endémique qui a dansé comme noté la ici
il faut qu'on soit capable de les
éveiller plus leur montrer que c'est
possible
autant pour eux
principalement jaurès à travailler avec
les enfants j'ai travaillé cet été aux
sons d'amitié autochtone de lanaudière
j'étais animatrice à quinze jours que
j'ai vraiment eu un coup de coeur pour
la les enfants puis c'est pour ça que
j'aimerais me diriger en pédiatrie plus
particulièrement pour retourner dans ma
communauté un mois
[Musique]
m